What Makes You Unique?
Just as no two snowflakes are alike, you are like no one else.
There has been only one Beethoven, one Michelangelo,...
...one Churchill, one Da Vinci, one Gandhi - and only one you.
How many people can do what you can do?
Among 10,000 unique human skills,...
...everyone has at least 5 to 10 uncommon skills they excel at.
If you can sing, calculate the odds, track bird migrations,...
...or know which direction is north better than 100 random people,..
...your gift puts you in the top 1% of the population.
When you start calculating the odds as you add in more of your gifts and talents...
...-having just five skills means you are one in ten billion likely to have that combination:
Rarity equals (5 at 1/100) equals 1/100 times 1/100 times 1/100 times 1/100 times 1/100 equals 1/10 billion.
That is more people than are alive on the Earth today.
The paradox is that you are both truly unique...
...and one of a countless multitude at the same time.
With uniqueness comes responsibility as only you have the gifts,...
...talents and potential to excel at the unique tasks...
...which define your destiny and your life calling.
If you do not fulfill your life calling, it will go undone,...
...or be done by someone else in a very different way.
Often, the victor in the human race is the person who makes the race their own.